I am where opera and football collide
Towe had a long journey to the United
States from Tonga
but his journey to center stage in the
Opera House took much longer
my name is Thao Papua I am an operatic
tenor and I am an immigrant from the
Kingdom of Tonga
[Music]
my name is Minnie Driver I am an actress
a singer and I am an immigrant I believe
nothing is more American than its
immigrants so I'm teaming up with great
big story to celebrate those that have
come here and left their mark
[Music]
when we moved to America I was seven
years old my parents wanted us nine kids
to have a education and so America was
the land of opportunity I started
playing football when I was 10 I was
fast I was strong I knew that my vehicle
into college was through playing
football it turns out Tao was a pretty
good linesman so good in fact that when
he graduated from college he was drafted
by the Cleveland Browns
but it was his taste in music that often
put him in the spotlight before a game
everybody is listening to rock and roll
heavy metal and I was the person on the
side listened to also their me Oh since
you know inspire me and then I got
injured I ProFlowers my foot and didn't
know what to do because football was the
only thing I knew a year later I just
decided that I better follow my other
love so town moved to New York to pursue
his other passion opera I didn't know a
single soul here I didn't know like how
do you become an opera singer the only
thing I knew from my playbooks in
playing football was you gotta have a
plan so I thought to myself well to meet
people if I get a job working in a
restaurant across the street from
Juilliard you're gonna have operatic
singers conductors coming in his plan
worked he met a man who helped him
secure an audition at the Juilliard
School of Music I got into Juilliard on
a full scholarship I was sort of playing
catch-up because my colleagues were
learning their soul tension when there
were 17 18 years old
[Music]
and after three years of rigorous
training he graduated from Juilliard
top program he has since travelled the
world singing in opera houses and on
concert stages and today among opera
fans tap opera is a big name I was
blessed to run around and sack
quarterbacks and now I sing love songs
to Sopranos I'd like to live in the
moment at my moment now is I am very
happy to be an opera singer to a young
Polynesian that is chasing their dreams
set your goals high dream big and make
it reality
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]